[Music]  tensions are running high on Keeping Up  with the Kardashians here's your first  look Scott Disick secretly brings a  woman on the family vacation to Costa  Rica  did you guys hear what Chelsea said no  yeah she said you know she was so nice  she was a Chelsea Handler I don't know  talking about Chelsea Clinton  oh no what am i doing up for a baron  Trump that's nice that Chelsea did that  but I think even Chelsea Handler no  Scott how are you feeling hmm-what  without a weird question gas blows let's  cut the bull the Courtney sisters  eventually catch Scott in his lie and  make him squirm at dinner it's pretty  obvious that the girls know something's  up nobody really wants to say what's on  their mind and if this dinner isn't  awkward enough these fire dancers have  to come out and start doing hole or  hoops I mean I already felt like under  fire  [Music]